that was still at a time where I think
we could shoot and we wouldn't draw a
huge crowd although I do remember people
yelling to Danny when we were driving
around the blocks we had to do this
giant loop around this one neighborhood
in Philly we would just go up and down
the street and no one knew our show but
everybody knows Danny so the neighbors
were out on their Stoops and every time
we would pass by they would yell out hey
Danny hey Danny come on over Danny I'll
make you some ziti and then we'd be
passing and turn around we'd come back
around and we had a joke running joke in
the car about it getting more extreme
like oh Danny come over and let me tie
you up in the bay
[Music]
[Applause]